[Music]
welcome back to cbs this morning we have
newly revealed video from the january
6th assault on the capitol
the government says it shows a local
leader of the far
right proud boys pushing past police on
the capitol steps
one officer who was injured that day was
michael fanon of dc's metropolitan
police
who was beaten unconscious he's now
trying to hold rioters and their
political supporters accountable for the
mayhem chris vancleve spoke with officer
fanon and two of his allies republican
congressman
adam kinzinger and democratic
congressman eric swalwell in an
interview
you are seeing only on cbs this morning
chris good morning to you
good morning there are certainly days up
here that start to feel like the
twilight zone when you hear
members minimizing what happened on
january 6th
one republican has speculated the fbi
was involved that's a conspiracy theory
another has compared the rioters to
tourists we are going to meet an officer
who was here on the sixth who battled
that crowd for his life and is now
battling for truth
and he is finding something that is in
short supply here on the hill these days
bipartisan support and even friendship
fight
you're seeing what d.c police officer
michael pinon saw on january 6th
all holy hell broke loose next thing you
know we were just
you know in a hand-to-hand just battle
his body cam rolled as he was pulled
into the crowd of rioters outside the
capitol
and attacked i was tortured i was beaten
i was you know struck with a taser
numerous times
at the base of my skull and i posed no
threat
at one point you were unconscious
correct how was that like a necessity
other than the fact that they wanted to
torture
an officer and if they're willing to do
that to you they were willing to do that
to a member of congress
absolutely he was forced to the ground
suffered a mild heart attack and a brain
injury
fearing for his life he called out i
have kids
six months later the scars from that day
are still with him
working through the emotional fallout
he's no longer fighting the mob
outside the capitol but some members of
congress
he rushed in to protect my initial
feelings were
a feeling of abandonment i speak to a
lot of police officers and that's the
overwhelming
feeling is that we've been abandoned as
efforts to downplay january 6th
grow louder last week 21 house
republicans voted to deny fanon and
fellow officers the highest
congressional honor for their heroism
in an attempt he thinks not to
acknowledge the attack
itself which is you know to me
far more repulsive than voting against
you know giving cops a medal fanon has
become friends with republican
congressman adam kinzinger
and democratic congressman eric swalwell
the three coming together in a joint
interview hoping to show it's possible
to disagree and still get along when you
sit here and you see the strength of
fanon here you know openly talking about
some of the emotional struggles he has
like as dudes that's something we don't
like doing i'm a military guy he's a cop
it's not something that
you know is in our lexicon but it's
important to hear it and where they all
agree
the need for a 9 11 style commission to
investigate january 6th
but that was blocked by senate
republicans the bottom line of aldi
it's cowardice because it takes strength
to tell the truth if you believe
antifa and blm actually attacked the
capital you should want a january 6
commission
but if you believe that it was act that
you've been lying about it the whole
time
then you don't want a january 6
commission that's why we have to do it
do you worry about more violence yes
here yes the best antidote against that
is unity among democrats and republicans
saying
we're not going to let that happen again
you know we may not agree on who the
president
is right now and what that person is
trying to do but we at least agree
in the process in the democracy that
brought that about
do you think if there is a commission or
anything congress does to look into
january 6 at this point will be
looked at as credible if you're going to
enact policies to make sure this never
happens again as the
independent bipartisan september 11
commission did
it has to be independent bipartisan and
as far
away from this building as possible mike
is there anything that
any questions you have from one six that
haven't been answered i'm done like
tiptoeing through the tulips here
the questions i have are you know to
what extent if any did
uh are political leaders involve
themselves in the events of
january 6th if there was uh
participation from
members of congress from their staff as
an officer that served that day
i certainly would like to know that like
as an american i believe very strongly
in a in a
two-party system um
right now one of those parties has a
cancer
and we gotta cut it out and until we do
that we're not gonna be able to move
forward as a nation
cbs news is not aware of any evidence
that indicates a member of congress
aided the rioters on january 6th nearly
500 people
have been charged and the fbi says
hundreds more
may soon be facing charges as well
officer fanon has been a regular
presence up here on the hill trying to
meet with members of congress that have
been minimizing what happened on january
6.
last week he says a house republican
member refused to even shake his hand
and he has been unable to get a meeting
with house minority leader kevin
mccarthy
mccarthy's office says the leader is
happy to meet with vanone
but has not received an official meeting
request
anthony chris thank you that's that's
pretty astonishing and
what's also astonishing is every time we
see another angle uh or another
body camera from from this assault on
january 6 it it just looks scarier and
scarier every time
yeah an independent bipartisan
commission i'm interested in what they
would find but also what they will not
find as chris mentioned there's no
evidence someone in congress
cooperated in any way with the rioters
let's put that in a report if that's
what the investigators find
i think the scariest thing in all of
this an investigation is not going to
change the minds and hearts of people
who think
that wasn't a big deal yeah i don't
understand when your house is attacked
as
congress was you don't agree to an
investigation first breach in over 200
years
yep